hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of awesome build where this week
we're going to be focusing on building a
set piece now I've never built anything
on awesome build this large before and
I'm pretty excited about it it's going
to be pretty cool I think you guys are
going to enjoy it but it's going to be a
lot of stuff so I'm going to be probably
breaking it up into two episodes so
today we're going to focus on building
the structure and then next week we'll
focus more on dressing it up and this
particular set piece is going to be a
sci-fi corridor you want to make a short
film or feature film or whatever you
just want to make a cool prop you want
to do like an alien's themed haunted
house or something like that this might
be kind of cool but it's going to be
kind of like your basic octagonal space
corridor it's gonna be pretty generic
but I'm going to show you how to make it
so that it's customizable so that you
can reuse it for different purposes and
different projects or even the same
project but when you dress it up it'll
look like different corridors so you can
just build the structure once and then
keep dressing the inside over and over
to make it look like different things
let's go to the drawing board let's map
out kind of how I've got it in my head
while I would think I can build it get
our basic measurements and start cutting
our lumber and building okay so I want
to have your kind of basic octagonal
design for this corridor so in order to
do so I'm going to build the framework
and basically the bones of the skeleton
of it and then we can fill in the inside
with whatever we want it's going to be
cheap objects that we can find around
the house so that we can get really
cheap at the dollar store the hardware
store and most of us can be comprised of
junk on the inside but the bones of it
are going to be constructed out of wood
so that it is it's somewhat sturdy but
still lightweight easy to move around
easy to break down and easy to transport
so basically what I want to do is create
a structure that is going to be able to
hold up the walls but it doesn't have to
sport a ton of weight
I think a good height is going to be
about six and a half feet so I'm going
to use two by threes and I'm going to
take the two by threes and I'm going to
cut them to a six and a half foot
lengths then I'll take a two by three
and I'm going to cut it into two foot
pieces one down here and one up here now
I'm going to have a four foot by eight
foot sheet of plywood that's based going
to be the walls of the structure so I
want to have enough room on my six foot
piece that I have enough my four foot in
the middle that's going to be like the
center piece so then I need to cut a
couple more pieces as my support
structure okay so these support
structures are going to be 21 inches
from the farthest end of the farthest
end so 21 inches and then from the
inside will be 16 from ended and what
that means is when I'm I tore it it's
going to look like this basically I'm
going to cut 45s on either side and so
from this length this length will be 21
inches from this length of this length
will be 16 I feel like this is a good
framework for a free-standing wall
that's why I'm going with the 2 foot and
the 21 by the 16 yeah and the 21 overall
length or my mitered edges I want it to
be almost like a rib cage we're going to
build six of these we'll have three on
either side to help give it enough
support where I can have one on either
side and one in the middle so we'll have
our fourth by eight foot sheet of
plywood and then we'll have support
piece here on the center and one on the
end all right then we're going to tie it
the top and the bottom together with one
by two 8 foot length and when we get to
it I'll show you what I mean by that all
right well our measurements are pretty
simple I'm just going to start making my
cuts and start assembling all right so
once I cut my six six
foot pieces out of the two by threes I
cut 12 two foot lengths and 12 of my
mitered that was 21 overall
now to put the pieces together
originally I was going to use some of
these metal brackets but they're kind of
expensive and for the first few I kind
of realized I didn't need to use them so
I just pulled out some metal strap cuz
it's much cheaper
I have rolls of it so I just kind of cut
pieces of that off and use that to tie
it together basically once you screw in
one side in order to get it nice and
snug I shoot the other one in a bit of
an angle so it kind of pulls that bottom
piece in nice and tight I flip it over
the same thing the other side
and now I'm ready to put in my mitered
piece basically my support strut
pre-drill some holes so I didn't split
my wood
and it shuts miss cruising to that nice
and snug all right there's one as I said
I just have to make six just like that
once I have all six of them I propped
them up like that and this is where I'm
going to use that 8 foot 1 by 3 I was
talking about
so I'm use two of those one at the top
one at the bottom to hold it all
together
let's make sure they're evenly spaced
give one on either end and then one of
the four-foot mark right in the center
so
you can see it's freestanding so then I
flipped it over got my four by eight
sheet of plywood drop that on there and
you can use whatever thickness you want
this is an eighth inch sheet it's very
thin very lightweight and I just screw
it right to my two buckles
all right now I took another 4x8 sheet
and I measured out 21 inches
cut them down and your four out of a
sheet those are basically to serve as
the top and bottom of our four to a wall
cleaning up the edges with moving the
sandpaper the bottom ones I just tent
into place
from the tap ones
and I just played another or by a cheat
on the taps is my temporary seal just to
give you guys an idea of the effect
alright guys that's all the time we have
for today I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode and make sure you tune in next
week where I'm going to show more about
how to dress up the inside and stuff
like that and make it look cool in
sci-fi again really really cheap it's
going to be using stuff that you find
around the house things that you may
throw away like using old styrofoam or
old plastic containers or stuff you
might find at the dollar store I'm going
to go over a variety of different things
that you can use to kind of dress up the
interior of your space corridor and some
different ways to light it and shoot it
so you can get a very cool and dynamic
look out of your whatever it is you're
filming so yeah make sure you tune in
for that I hope this inspires you guys
to go out and build some stuff and once
again thanks so much for tuning in for
supporting the show you guys rack see
you next week